[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
the way that you write jokes is sketch
garlic powder super important garlic
powder
catch a happy hour
[Music]
it's ridiculous
I'm senior to you no
next order of business we must determine
the age of consent the whole gang got
access to an open bar
Arc is gay I love these guys
we need big economy we love the Jews we
love [ __ ] and Jews
[Music]
a Jewish horse and
yeah
Gillian keeps a special came out on
Tuesday it premiered privately on
gillingkeeves.tv for just ten dollars
and included a full hour of brand new
sketch comedy as well as onstage
performances welcome to Gillian key the
sketch show
I'm pretty drunk
I definitely want to come back out again
and do that again it could well
beforehand my friend kept being like you
have to intro the show and I was like
totally don't worry I'm gonna nail it
welcome to Geelong he's scared the sky
show I watched the full special last
night and thought it was amazing but I
wanted to hear from the comedy fans the
comedy community see what we all thought
collectively of this special so I put it
up in our community section thoughts on
the Gillian Cube special and the reviews
were all very positive very very
positive with the number one complaint
being I wish it was longer Joe Mack said
it was incredible only complaint is I
wish it was longer incredible just wish
it never ended Clipper said wish it was
longer I'm Toby picked Karen and not
only am I a military vet but I'm also a
grilled meat connoisseur I went through
hell and back to defend this country now
I'm traveling all over it to find the
best greasy grub
when I was in War I went through a
pretty traumatic experience that left my
memory fragmented but my taste buds
perfectly intact whoa and sure sometimes
oh not cool gang
but I'll never forget these tasty
flavors so join me while I'm trying to
remember who I am with some
Unforgettable food I am the grill
sergeant
[Music]
there were 10 total sketches including
the opening scene I thought they were
all fantastic there seems to be a
consensus top three among people that
commented on this post receiving the
most comments by far was the compliance
sketch
the gold Brothers
and Trump Hitler
Henry said absolutely hilarious my
favorite is the Trump sketch I almost
feel out of my chair laughing so hard BJ
said Trump rewriting history was awesome
and the grill sergeant
hot house where I hear he's got a spicy
chicken dish it's hotter than Napalm
let's check it out gang hey nice pork
chop [ __ ] hey I'll beat the [ __ ] out
of you
I'll bust your ass boy
don't [ __ ] with me
that's whoa whoa there's old people out
on the in another restaurant and like
when we pulled up they were everyone
were like oh [ __ ] it's Guy Fieri and
like me walking in I was like [ __ ] you
[ __ ] they were all like holy
[ __ ] yeah it was pretty fun golden
brothers is going to be a [ __ ]
classic I will come back for a laugh
gold Bros was the best I think overall
hilarious oh it's the next one oh golden
brothers
oh nice we like hired all these kids how
do we how do we preface this all right
bro
we hired a bunch of children look I
didn't know anything about it we didn't
really have a script for this one this
is abstract art this is abstract art all
right this is Jackson Pollock
I'm carter gold
um Bobby Gold I'm check gold
I'm the daddy oh and for your
information
JTV said Grill Sergeant is probably one
of the funniest skits I've ever seen
that and golden brothers were my two
favorites compliance was so funny
compliance in the airplane sketch
airplane sketch is definitely my top
three for sure my top four airplane
sketch was amazing Golds was great pure
chaos Trump Hitler was funny as hell
compliance was great lots of amazing
sketches they also did a sketch based
off Shane's coming up with the age of
consent bit that he opened up with in
his stand-up special life from Austin I
was thinking about the first time like
Congress had to come up with age of
consent
that'd be like the powdered wigs and
stuff that had to be a rough day for the
fellas
it's like some guy coming up first like
from Rhode Island 12. and I was like ew
ew no dude the way that you write jokes
and there are other people who are like
this like the way Chappelle writes jokes
is sketch like if you see like one of
his bits you can also like
it comes almost with visuals yeah and I
remember jokes I think you said that
yeah maybe and we did it well well the
one joke you saw me do a joke at the
seller it was so that's just a sketch
yeah like it wasn't even a joke you were
pitching it I think you read it just a
sketch I don't want to give it away can
we tell the premise the premise you've
seen the joke it's yeah it's at the
beginning of my special yes uh yeah the
guy's coming up with age of consent self
out yeah the guy having to guess so
funny as soon as I said it yeah he was
like that's a sketch and of course it
wouldn't be a Shane Gillis sketch show
without anyone bringing up SNL which is
honestly hilarious to even compare the
two at this point I mean with their own
money and their own friends Shane Gillis
and Gillian keeves were able to make 10
better sketches than anything SNL's put
out in the last 25 years and that's an
under reaction James said best sketch
comedy of the last decade plus easily
eat your hearts out SNL SNL [ __ ] all
the way up young bull for life bye bye
SNL does Comedy Central even exist
anymore I haven't seen anything funny on
there except for South Park shing's
talents would have been wasted on SNL
Gill and keeves wouldn't have been this
good this special was I think the first
of its kind but a great Showcase of both
Shane and mckeever's talents [ __ ] yeah
brov this special is top tier comedy all
the way through plain and simple and SNL
wouldn't have even allowed half of these
sketches on their show SNL is just
basically a propaganda Factory at this
point you think NBC's gonna allow Trump
Hitler on their show all 10 of these
Masterpiece sketches probably would have
been shot down by SNL just like Shane
was
we wanted to make a movie about Hitler
his rise to power and then his
inevitable demise
Studio loved it the cast was set and the
script was incredible but we couldn't
find anybody in Hollywood that would
play Hitler nobody wanted to do it we
looked everywhere but no one wanted to
risk their careers
but
we did find one person
[Music]
I'm Hitler
they didn't have anyone to play Hitler
so they called me the studio called me
they said Donald could you please get us
out of this I'm actually glad they were
able to charge for this and everyone
could make some money off this season
because like Shane was saying on
flagrant with the first season they
released it for free and it was great
for his career but for the people that
don't do stand up it didn't really have
the same effect if we put this out for
free I get to make money because I get
to go tour with it yeah yeah one of the
results in ticket sales they get nothing
so when you say you had to put this on a
paywall but when you said you paid 270
are you also paying them out of that or
are you waiting if you haven't seen it
yet and are interested in purchasing the
Gillian Cube special head over to
gilliancieves dot TV it only costs you
ten dollars and you have access to it
for the full year thank you for watching
this video and also make sure to
subscribe to joke world if you haven't
done so already the fastest growing
community of Comedy fans in the world
and if you want even more comedy if
you're an even bigger comedy fan than
just subscribing to this channel which
you definitely should but head over to
our Instagram page WE Post similar
content we're featuring new open mikers
every day we're featuring your famous
comedians that you already know love and
we'll send you free stickers in the mail
free joke World stickers if you DM us
thank you again for watching I'll see
you Monday with the comedy news
[Music]